welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanston and I am both titillated and
terrified to be theorizing about what
the lore is going to be in the Five
Nights at Freddy's movie today FNAF has
a dedicated and passionate fan Mason
because there's never been one
officially verified timeline
disagreements of the lore are pretty
common however today's special
fun and I ask that everyone keeps it
civil in the comments especially when
replying to other commenters the series
is a jumpscaring cupcake in it it's all
in good fun as a warning up front this
is a full spoilers video while we
obviously don't know what exactly is
going to happen in the movie our
speculation is going to be based off of
all of the games and will probably touch
on things that might happen in the
future movies so to be safe spoiler
alert for all the games books and
possibly all three movies that are
slated as of now now settle in while
Auntie Anna tells you a story not long
ago I thought you know what would make a
good movie Kingdom Hearts and this is
because they would have the opportunity
to clean up that absolute batshit story
and just make it simple and clean and I
would bet that's the opportunity Scott
is taking as well Scott has said that
when he made the first game the story
wasn't laid out how it exists today
since he didn't know it would turn into
such a huge thing and while he tried to
stay faithful to the things he
established in the first games there
were times he had to change things in
retcon too that's a big part of what
makes the story so tangled and hard to
part out and you have to remember that
this movie is going out to the general
public they're already going to be a
little confused why there's a Freddy and
a golden Freddy so I'm almost certain he
has taken this Clean Slate opportunity
to create a completely different Canon
that's a bit easier to grasp all that is
to say that while we can use the games
as a baseline we cannot take them as
long as the slightest so with that let's
jump into some of the most pressing
questions that came with the release of
the trailer
so one of the most agreed upon things in
the game's lore is that William afton's
Family consists of William Ashton his
wife who is thus far unnamed and his
children Michael Elizabeth and youngest
son the crying child whose some
theorizes named Evan with that let's
look at the argument for each side
starting with the argument for why
William Afton is not going to be Mike's
Dad one of the biggest reasons is that
if Mike gets the night guard job from
William then it would be extremely hard
to believe that he wouldn't recognize
his dad's face and or voice looking at
the age that the actor playing young
Mike is he would definitely be old
enough to remember what his dad looked
and sounded like even if he was going
under the Alias Steve Ragland that is by
the way definitely an alias the
character's name on IMDb is William
Afton so they haven't changed his name
for the movie or anything another
argument for William not being Mike's
son is that in the game some theories
suggest that at the time the first game
takes place William would have already
been dead one theory around the games is
that Mike is getting these security
guard positions at the restaurants to
investigate the locations where his dad
murdered people which would be his
reason for staying in the position and
coming back night after night even one
possessed animatronics are trying to
kill him in that theorized timeline
William would have already died in the
spring lock costume and while Scott has
said that finding a strong enough
connection between Mike and the building
to make him keep returning was one of
the biggest challenges while writing the
script in the movie his reason may be
because of his sister either needing
that job to pay his bills and maintain
custody over her or because she forms a
connection with golden Freddy and
insists on coming back or possibly to
help Vanessa which we'll get back to
later the point is he has more potential
reasons to say than he did in the games
so the father-son connection might not
be as important as it was in the games
finally rumors were going around that
IMDb said that Garrett Hines had been
cast in the role of Mike's dad but I
don't think that's true IMDb doesn't
list that gentleman's name or the
character at all and if you're thinking
it might have been removed that's not
possible IMDb doesn't remove factual
credits and it doesn't matter who asks
for it to be removed that's just policy
but now let's look at why he could still
be William's son first of all it's a
pretty juicy little plot twist and it's
a little wild to think that such an
integral part of the game's story would
be scrapped and in the first game
Michael Afton is working under the name
of Mike Schmidt so calling the movie
character Mike Schmidt and basing the
movie on the first game would obviously
lead one to think that this would be
Michael Afton though it's very possible
that Mike himself believes his actual
name to be Mike Schmidt and doesn't know
of his connection to William at all need
energy mean it now that's the job for
one shot
yum one shot energy twos are a healthy
and convenient energy boosting
supplement candy for gamers athletes
YouTube hosts everybody really one shot
makes energy choose and focus choose so
you can choose if you want to rev up or
Zone in each energy too has 75
milligrams of pure caffeine plus 600
milligrams of additional nootropics to
give you a serious energy boost that
works immediately as you chew the Focus
Shoes come in new Rockstar's theme
packaging we use them all the time to
get a natural boost of focus and energy
with B C D and E vitamins plus zinc to
help with immune system support and the
amino acid tyrosine both Energy Chews
and focus shoes are plant-based
naturally sweetened and designed to give
you the energy and focus you need
without a bunch of fillers and chemicals
get started with one shot energy today
by going to one shotenergy.com new
rockstars for 10 off your order
regarding being able to recognize
William's face and voice there are a few
different reasons Mike might not one
option is that they may have never
talked face to face when Mike is an
adult we haven't gotten footage of them
being in the same room together yet it's
only been a phone call and if you want
to get really deep in the weeds this
editing trick where they aren't actually
having this conversation with each other
or even in the same time period
necessarily to be honest I don't really
think that this is the case but it's
just a reminder that trailers trick us
all the time and we have to keep our
minds open to the possibilities but
assuming they are talking to each other
through the phone if you haven't seen
your dad in years and years and you're
on the phone with someone going by a
different name the situation is so out
of context that your brain probably
wouldn't piece it together or William
could easily be putting on a fake voice
to go with his fake name another option
is that William might have left the
family when Mike was still a baby or
even before he was born we will be
getting a younger mic flashback but
that's not to say that William would
have still been in the picture during
that flashback era I'm in my flashback
era but it's possible Mike's mom might
have gotten remarried or that Mike was
adopted by foster parents and that might
also explain why his last name is
Schmidt instead of Afton another thing
that might point to William being Mike's
dad is the smugness William seems to
have when talking to Mike about the job
almost like he's one a game yes now
admittedly he could just be trying to
recruit any random person for the
position so he can fulfill his murderous
desires and the smugness might be just a
result of him finding a new victim but
it would make a lot of sense if William
left the family early on in Mike's life
but continue to keep tabs on him and his
sister purposefully lining his jobs and
aliases up with things he knew would
intersect with their lives and there are
a couple of points that could go either
way one being that Abby who is replacing
Elizabeth is an anagram for baby an
animatronic first scene in Five Nights
at Freddy's sister location who is
believed to be possessed by Elizabeth
this link could support the argument for
them being William's kids but you could
also argue that a support so I'm not
being related to William since in the
games William made circus baby when
Elizabeth was still alive and had a
close bond with her dad which clearly
isn't the case here finally in the
trailer we see shots where William wears
a yellow shirt with a blue tie and Mike
wears a blue shirt with a yellow tie
costuming decisions have a lot of
thought put into them and while I
believe this definitely demonstrates a
link between them this could be a
familial link or it could be a good
verse versus evil two sides of the same
coin type of deal speaking of the Afton
family who is William's youngest son
known colloquially as the crying child
not gonna lie at first when I saw the
character young afraid boy on IMDb I
thought that had to be him young afraid
boy is like when you copy and paste
something off the internet into your
essay but use the thesaurus on all the
words you don't get caught for
plagiarizing but no Mike and Abby's
brother is definitely the child in the
car whose name is Garrett played by
Lucas Grant his Instagram is filled with
pictures of him with the kids playing
Abby and young Mike and if you needed
more evidence Wyatt Parker who plays
young Mike has the same picture with the
caption hanging out with the new best
bro so all evidence points to little
brother also this is a good time to
point out the difference between looking
at what the kids accounts run by their
families are posting and actively
bugging them with questions please do
not harass the child actors or their
families about this movie do not
yeah
but what about the woman on the ground
is that their mom that's definitely what
I'm leaning towards I pointed out the
newspaper on the table in our breakdown
of the trailer and that's because it
looks really purposefully placed in the
shot if the newspaper is purposefully
placed I think she might have ended
things after reading about William being
a suspect in the missing children's case
and maybe knew something or she might
have read about their youngest child
dying I could also see this being
related to drugs or alcohol and it's
even possible that she's not dead here
and just passed out perhaps as evidence
that she's unfit to care for Abby
yeah
the two possibilities I see are Mike
Abby and Vanessa clock the blue collared
shirt and badge or maybe Vanessa and her
husband and daughter though I lean more
towards the first one since it would be
strange to me that they wouldn't be
there when she's in the hospital if it
were an emergency since you would likely
have her badge and info on her at the
time of the injury or the hospital could
contact the police to get her emergency
contact info so I leaned towards Abby
drawing them as the Three Musketeers of
sorts since on the topic of Vanessa many
people are suspicious that she may be a
secret villain in this story I think
this originated from the fact that in
FNAF security breach she's tied to vanny
the antagonist so some speculate that
isn't actually Vanessa but regardless
this is where her being the bad guy
stems from and
she knows a lot about the pizzeria her
being there would allow for eyes to be
kept on Mike and she might be
intentionally misleading Mike by telling
him that the animatronics want to make
Abby like them on the flip side You
could argue that Vanessa is trying to
protect Mike by letting him know what's
been going on and giving him the heads
up that this place is dangerous she
might truly believe that the
animatronics intentions are to make Abby
like them and she seems to be close
enough to the siblings for Mike to stay
with her at the hospital and Abby to
draw a picture of all of them together
it's possible that Vanessa may
eventually turn into a bad guy in a
future movie but there's one more reason
she may be wanting to help Mike out in
this one and for that I turn to the
ghost children
please
as I've said in my breakdowns there's a
huge amount of debate over which kid is
supposed to represent Freddy and which
kid is supposed to represent golden
Freddy in this scene and it's time to
throw my hat in the ring assuming that
one of them is supposed to be golden
Freddy it's this golden Freddy is
clearly supposed to stand out in this
movie he's been shown alone with Abby a
few times now and is clearly an ally of
some sort these kids back here are all
in a line with this one being the only
one standing out and this kid is Grant
feely the only one not listed on IMDb
yet all of the others are listed as
ghost kid number X only the one standing
out isn't listed I'm not done one big
thing to note is that Grant had to dye
his hair blonde for the film that is not
insignificant so I think that Grant is
playing Vanessa's brother who was one of
the murder victims in the 80s it
explains why Vanessa is still focused on
the case and it sets up a beautiful
parallel between Vanessa and Mike
working together and golden Freddy and
Abby working together sibling power now
there's one thing that might put a
slight wrench in this theory in the
games golden Freddy is possessed by a
girl named Cassidy and some believe it
is dual possessed by Cassidy and The
Crying child a big clue being in the
first game when golden Freddy appears
you see it's me flash and if the
security guard is Mike his dead brother
saying it's me lines up I'm not worried
about the Cassidy aspect because Cassidy
hasn't even been introduced as a major
character in the games or books yet so
replacing her with someone that adds
Stakes to the story makes all the sense
in the world to me but in the trailer
you can see it's me when the lights
start flashing and their brother helping
them as golden Freddy would also make
total sense so maybe it is a dual
possession thing but with Vanessa's
brother and Mike and Abby's brother who
knows but what I am pretty dang sure of
is that golden Freddy is supposed to
stand out and color of shirt be damned I
really doubt they would be listed as
ghost child number four with the rest of
the crew
please
all that being said I think the five
letters together represent the ghost
children with the red being golden
Freddy and as for the one off to the
side this could really be a few people
Abby Mike hear it potentially Afton even
it's really hard to say for sure
for those who don't know spring Bonnie
is the name of the spring lock suit that
one could get into and spring trap is
what the possessed suit is called after
William dies prior to his death spring
Bonnie after death springtrap at least
in the games that being said this
trailer is making it seem like William
is still alive and kicking and the
suit's still in pretty decent shape so I
would probably say he's in the spring
Bonnie suit you can even see a little
cheek if you turn up the brightness but
I wouldn't be surprised if at the end of
the movie he gets killed and then you
have that moment where the camera
lingers on the suit and then all of a
sudden the eyes light up purple and it
cuts to credits I'll take my check
please
well The Intruders seemed like bit Parts
who get immediately killed off they
might hold more weight than you think
cat Sterling the actress playing Max
said in a tick tock that Max does have a
story that ties some things together and
affects the outcome of the story and if
we look at Christian Stokes Twitter the
actor playing Hank his bio specifically
says uncle Hank and upon the trailer's
release he tweeted don't rule out all
Hank yet he might surprise you so what
do we think I'll leave you with that
question who do you think these
characters might be how does Carl with
his cool midnight motorist t-shirt fit
into all this and who would that make
the guy in front I look forward to
reading your theories in the meantime
you can follow me on Twitter at it'sanna
vanson follow And subscribe to new
rockstars at new rockstars and hey if
you like live discussions debates and
reactions to the titles you can't get
enough of be sure to subscribe to our
live channel the break room Keep It Fun
[Music]
thank you